what's the difference between thinking
and knowing wow we think we know a lot
and we think we know out of judgment
you know we're very judgmental society
and and we're kind of desperate and uh
in the in the you know thinking we now
we got to know we got to know I mean
really I gotta know so I'm gonna look at
this thing in order to know and I'm
going to know
when I judge it because when you judge
it you go oh I know it's la la I know
it's this I know it's that so that is a
kind of a desperate need to think you
know and it serves the ego well because
the ego feels smart and it protects us
because oh I know I don't have to go
near there because I know what that is
so thinking that you know comes out of
judgment and of which there's a lot when
you know that you know
you know it because you know what you
feel it it's visceral this is why we
have this
degree of sensitivity and um
you know people say oh you're
Clairvoyant no not Clairvoyant just a
higher tuning on that
intuitive intuitive senses you know
people talk about
um emotional uh intelligence the first
time I heard that yeah every once in a
while I go to a therapist and then I go
I don't know
but I had a therapist once oh you have a
you you have a really strong emotional
intelligence and I said what is that and
she described it as you know a very high
intuition toward this is truth or this
is serving me it's a very high intuition
which makes sense because you have to
have that you know when you're growing
up and you're unsure so you start
observing things like crazy to figure
out what is going on now you're not
observing these things to judge them
you're observing these things for
survival so you're open to what is it
you're really looking at it and feeling
it up
right so that's a highly attuned
intuition that's knowing when you know
everybody's felt it you know I just knew
I met him and I knew I met the guy was
going to marry her I knew this was the
house for me when I walked in the door
or I knew you know people talk about it
in that way that's all that is it's a
hit with intuition and then a trust and
then a moving forward with it but
there's a lot of thinking you know you
know thinking I know I know oh yeah I
know I got it
sort of a glib judgmental you know
thing and judgment is something that
it's another one of those things you
want to separate out a little bit and go
God I'm being really judgmental aren't I
I'm just being really judgmental of this
person
um during the pandemic a couple of
things have happened you know because we
don't see anybody I mean we've been
pretty isolated my husband and I for a
long time we do see people but now that
I'm promoting the book and we promote
the film I'm meeting all kinds of people
so sometimes you know I think you know
somebody will say oh we want you on your
podcast and I'll kind of look into them
and see them and sometimes I'll go oh
they're from so this place and I don't
know anything about that place and
they're not going to know anything about
me and my first thing is protection to
protect myself because it's a little
nervous making putting yourself out
there particularly having not done it
for three years so the first thing might
be judgmental I start looking for ways
not to do that thing
and then I go and I do it and I talk to
this person I talk to a guy in Virginia
in coal mining you know and I thought
you know the first thing was like this
and man I love this man I love so when
we open ourselves to the human being the
other human being it's it's really quite
a spectacular thing and that's a reach
to know each other on a human level as
opposed to oh I know what that is that's
a guy from coal mining company and
Kansas who's you know wants to be a
radio host and
whatever it is you know uh the guy
turned out to be a high school teacher
which is
you know I have they're like
firefighters to me high school teachers
right now I think they're the great
Heroes of the world and you know after
the we did an interview together we
spoke as two human beings about the
state of education and his dedication to
teaching and you know you can't get
there if you judge somebody before you
even meet them
so it's all about moving forward with
open heart really we all need to to find
that Stillness in ourselves and open our
heart and walk forward with an open
heart because what are you going to
protect yourself from
you know covet okay we're a mass you
know I mean
we don't need to protect ourselves we
need to live we need to find ourselves
we need to listen to ourselves we need
to find a way out through guidance
sure well I mean it's understandable but
you don't know someone's agenda when you
come into an interview or you could say
the same for an audition someone could
say uh you know I love this person's
work and I know I'm perfect for it and
then they go and they're met with just a
stone wall and and they're crushed
because they thought they were going to
see me and they were going to go you
you're the one yes and it turns out they
barely they didn't even get your name
what's your name again okay and then
this is that's so beautifully said and
not only that that was a terrible
experience for actors to have to
constantly go in for auditions and it's
as if the people auditioning them were
trained to be like the parents I told
you about like nothing NADA not see you
for an artist not to be seen even when
they're working from their heart no
matter where they're working from
whether it's a concept in their head or
a concept in their art for them not to
be ex seen it's just it's criminal
really because they're the ones that are
going to lift us up out of this stuff we
should be going thank you for coming in
but so how do you handle that
do you emulate what you want
if you didn't like the way your mother
did it then do it that way for your
daughter and you'll heal yourself and
you'll pass on and evolve the next
Evolution to it if you don't like the
way the people are behaving towards you
change your attitude don't walk out
feeling Justified and ain't it awful
they're really shitty to me they didn't
even see once again I am right I think
I'm right once again the last 10 they're
all terrible you know it's really hard
if that person's Stone faced if you
don't take it personally because it
certainly has nothing to do with you
if you don't take it personally you just
look at them think maybe they had a bad
day and you look at them and lock eyes
and go Hi how are you they're going to
respond if you offer them your heart
they're going to respond and my counsel
to my actress is that's your job
Change the World by example
go in and be you know they say Be the
Change you want to see that's a real
thing it's a little harder to do than to
say but it's a wonderful practice we are
what we practice period you know if we
don't practice anything then the world's
going to be happening to us and we're
going to be like you know at effect to
whatever comes into our lives you know
if we practice certain things we
practice meditation so we can get a
handle on when we're behaving in ways we
don't like we can look and go yeah I'm
behaving in a way I really don't like
you know when we practice gratitude we
can raise our we can raise our our
vibration at will when we practice doing
the things that bring us joy we raise
our vibration we begin to to to take our
life in the directions that we want to
take it it's it's really simple
I it's really simple it's just a little
difficult believing and simplicity to
that degree
because you say in the book that the the
first piece of art that an artist
creates is their perfect life or the
life that's best suited for them
well hopefully but unfortunately you
know but that's the way I'd like people
to look at it you know people go I'm not
an artist I go you are an artist
your life is your first Masterpiece you
know you're either creating that or
you're creating it whether you are
consciously creating it and moving it in
the directions that you want to or
whether you're creating it with your own
thoughts whether they're negative or in
the middle you know you're just thinking
all the time thinking thinking looking
at screens you know just bubbling along
it's a reflection of everything you do
and everything you say and everything
you think combines together to make your
future that's going to be your next
moment this moment is going to unfold
into that moment and that moment is
going to unfold to the next so if this
moment you have brought yourself Joy on
purpose you've lifted your own frequency
out of your own practices then that will
flow into a different kind of moment
than if you hadn't done that consciously
does that make sense
so you you give people
um or you ask sorry not give but you you
ask your students to do different things
to raise their vibrations whether it's
just taking a walk in nature or petting
an animal well when they get morose
you know usually I'm teaching just
acting I mean I teach a lot of things
but but actors get morose people get
morose and they get complainy
and you know like what are you
complaining about you have a roof over
your head yeah do you have friends yeah
you know do you have car yards you can
eat yeah you know what are you
complaining about yeah but they're
they're righteously terrible things
going on in the world but you'll do
better with those things when you gain a
little control over your own
emotional state you can call it
vibration you could just call it
emotional state but that's in your
charge that's your responsibility and if
you're walking around like a sad attack
I call it would say Eeyore you know so
you know another student would be in a
critique and they would go yeah you know
it's a thing and the thing and I'd go oh
it's like Eeyore you know you know you
were in poos just walked around just
sort of morose and sad all the time
well you know
what's the movie where they go get out
of it snap out of it you want to smack
him and go
snap out of it instead I give them
exercises you know sometimes they get
into it collectively like right now we
are collectively in a kind of a morose
agreement about the pandemic
meanwhile the pandemic has made some
important adjustments by the way in life
but we don't look at those we just go
we're we're like oh boy the pandemic
you know ain't it awful
but it's brought about some group things
but I would come to class sometimes and
I would feel they were in a collective
unhappiness the whole room you can feel
it you know sometimes I come into class
and everybody's like let's go we got
work to do that's what I like to create
out of and if the room isn't like that
I'm going to address it and that's a
little different than some acting
classes you know but it's like
we're going to work from up here we're
not going to work from down here and if
you're working from down here sometimes
I just make them stand up and jump and
since the whole room is jumping up no no
and they're doing it like this I go no
it has to be at the same time so now I
have to listen to each other and then
they finally get at the same time by the
time they get at the same time they're
laughing and their energy is up
other times I think it's
you know it was a certain election that
happened and there was a certain
Collective
morosity I don't know I'm a roseness in
the room and I go what's going on
they're like so I I said when did when
is the last time you when this last time
you went out into nature when's the last
time you took a day I take days in
nature because I can't live without it
when's the last time you know nothing
nothing came the room was dead and they
went
seriously when is the last time you went
to you know the
Gardens or the ocean or the mountains or
took a walk in nature when is the last
that nothing
so I assigned them to go out so it could
be the mountains could be could be a
park but you had to go alone you had to
turn off your electronics and you had to
just be you had to just sit there and
observe things around the grass the tiny
things the large trees the ocean the
sand the little crabby bugs in the sand
just If You observe you know you stop
thinking when you observe so a lot of my
teaching has to do with observation
so I should just go out and and observe
and turn off the phone and do it for an
hour
and uh
but he came back to class and I said oh
and I said and then when you come home I
want you to find a rock
or let the rock find you and bring it to
class you know and before you pick it up
I would say it's just me before you pick
it up I would ask it permission because
that rock has lived there for quite some
time and you are moving it from its
natural environment so I would ask
permission and if you feel it's okay you
know take this rock that you spotted in
a special way and you know as a as a
thank you for this experience that you
hadn't bring it to class so I came to
class and there were these 50 rocks
lined up on the apron of the class they
were beautiful and the room was just
exactly with energy and they wanted to
talk about they wanted to talk mostly
about how disconnected they were from
nature how powerful it was you know one
young girl maybe the youngest in class
had never spent time in nature that's
what these telephones and social media
is doing to us had never thought it
never crossed her mind I think I'll go
to the beach by myself and take in the
power of the ocean I think I'll take a
walk in the woods and commune with trees
you know in Europe they have a whole
Forest bathing because they understand
the power of walking in forests and they
were crackling it was fantastic anyway
the young one got scared she said she
was really it was so big the energy was
so big and so different to her that it
scared her and I said well were you
scared like a bear was coming scared or
were you excited in a new kind of a way
and she said I was excited and the
minute was over I was she said I only
did 20 minutes because it was so big so
but the minute was over I wanted to do
it again like a roller coaster so you
know simple
simple things
are
very powerful
truth is very simple lies are very
complicated the more complicated thing
something is the more lies it has in it